ladies and gentlemen we are going to
watch today episode 1 of marvel's what
if this show looks so cool i'm excited
to have you guys join us for this ride
guys if you end up enjoying our reaction
would love it if you could subscribe hit
that notification bell to get notified
when our next reaction for what if is up
hit that like button too while you're at
it full length watch the logs recycle
with the time code will be over at our
patreon page we cover a whole bunch of
shows over there where the same tier you
get the option for both reaction
highlights and watch alongs included i
will think of more official ways to say
that eventually lastly
the wrong name is jaden
there's been a long time coming let's
really explore the multiverse now with
marvel's what if
[Music]
it would have been really cool if they
animated all this yeah
next time marvel
reality it's more than a linear path
it's a prism
of endless possibility where a single
choice can branch out into infinite
realities creating alternate worlds from
the ones you know
so excited
i am your guy through these vast new
realities oh cool follow me
and ponder the question
what if
the allied armies band together to
create a new kind of soldier a skinny
kid from brooklyn became captain america
but in another universe a single choice
created a whole new hero
dr skin
agent carter wouldn't you be more
comfortable in the booth no i'd prefer
to stay
there that's the moment
that created a new universe the nexus
event the serum will cause immediate the
subject will be
[Music]
howard
how old was it dropping we either do
this now or we lose the projects rogers
get in there he cop start you go in what
are you crazy i push the buttons i'm the
buttons gun
lose everything it has to be now you
know it's all up to you peggy
agent carter what are you doing this is
our only chance
did it work and then some you won't be
needing those hills anymore damn dang
i'd call this an absolute success what
an absolute failure i was promised an
army instead i get a girl i understand
this is not the desired outcome you have
a super soldier women aren't soldiers
they sure as hell don't fight on the
front lines he might break a nail
that's bradley whitford yep
yeah
brings that voice with him everywhere he
goes
it's like
oh
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
you were meant to be the one to end the
war now you and don't worry about me i
never was much of a dancer anyway oh
maybe you haven't found the right
partner
she'd still go for skinny steve yeah
he's he's not skinny where it counts in
his heart
tesseracts was the jewel of odin's
treasure room
able to hold the power to rewrite the
very laws of physics and unlock doors
across the universe
if we send a team tonight we can get our
hair out of your mind star i could go
great now you're both crazy fantastic
[Laughter]
what's this it was supposed to be your
uso let's go sell some war bonds costume
but i made a few upgrades your covert
skills need work then this is going to
be awkward
yeah
solo
[Music]
that was brilliant
[Laughter]
damn that shield is murdering nazis
oh
cool
sending in a fragile frow line to fight
for them fragile
[Music]
yeah
captain carter
i saw
oh i know exactly what to do with this
if your friend was taken prisoner by
hydra bucky's unit is now 50 kilometers
behind the front line if we're going to
take down hydra we'll need all the
friends we can get
i owe you one you owe me more than that
dum-dum duken
howling commandos
great
are you the 107th i'm here for sergeant
barnes
who are you supposed to be queen of
england
steve rogers sent me the name's captain
carter
steve
rogers
[Music]
hey peggy now you owe me one
[Laughter]
[Music]
i am not a gun
[Music]
yes sir i told stark to build it myself
yeah
awesome
[Music]
i love these tracking shots man
look at this this is great
oh
[Music]
what great wish fulfillment yeah
castle hydra champion of hydra shall be
summoned from beyond the stars
my champion
yours
oh damn
wow what a cool shot nice
third reich will fall
and hydra will rise from its ashes how
did it feel well to get the serum i'm no
longer screaming to be heard to be seen
to be in the room to be respected it's
like great chris evans impression
i'm still that skinny kid from brooklyn
now just in a big metal suit
you're more than the suit the suit is
nothing without the man inside you're my
hero steve
you're a hero
you're my hero too
oh hey what's going on no you continue
just pretend i'm not here
[Music]
oh no red skull the very head of hydra
is on that train we can end the war yeah
i've heard that one before something
about this smells as fresh as three day
old fish
or maybe you're just afraid of trains
quit yeah for free
i'm in position commencing operation
where eagles dare
where he goes dare
oh
thanks you almost ripped my arm off
[Laughter]
really toy with us on bucky really
peggy
no
oh wow
[Applause]
we gotta go
so steve become the winter soldier the
winter stomper
you said the hydra stomper was
indestructible it is was his name
is steve rogers not the hydra stomper
steve and we've lost
she should never been the field in the
first place would you shut up dude
ah foreign
i was wondering when you might visit me
i will tell you nothing he told me
everything
red skull believes he can unleash an
inter-dimensional force that will lead
hydra to world domination
no wonder hydra targeted rodgers you'd
need the stomper to get close colonel
you're lucky to even be in the room
scenes
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the ban of hydra has risen
what the bloody hell monsters
you are too late captain carter i have
summoned the champion
oh no
oh no
maybe we need a plan steve come on pal
don't give up on me you got to get me in
the suit the generator should give the
suit enough power
[Music]
oh no you okay
yep good because we don't have all day
but i could do this all day
that has even fully come out yet i might
be able to transpose the ingress and do
science stuff you mean transfer polarity
and reverse the suction okay being the
genius is my thing
come on speak to me baby
and everything's in german
i love howard in this episode
nice
sword and shield eddie lamar and i spent
a weekend together but she wasn't
teaching me
cut off the tentacle no
yeah
did you miss me
every second i told you it was
indestructible
[Laughter]
you were saying howard
oh
oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
you're a great team yeah
really helped out
you were there
no no no
i have to i can end this you owe me a
dance lesson oh
saturday night
oh no
[Music]
no
walk into dr strange too
sir
that's captain carter where's steve
rogers the war ended almost 70 years ago
damn you're going to be okay of course
we won the war her one choice gave birth
to a whole new history these are my
stories for i am
the watcher i watch i'm a creepy voyer
[Music]
it was a fast-paced rollicky 1940s
serial adventure 1940s comic adventure
right there you see
a lot of swashbuckling in action
intrigue and romance move like one was
shot like one animated like one
fascinating stuff
that was the same uh creature from
guardians 2 right
yeah i think so
big old tentacle beast
i'm sure we could look it up really
quick
it's cthulhu it's the crack
obelisk
multi-dimensional tentacled monster yeah
yeah devouring power sources that would
make a lot of sense yeah that's the same
one a lot of fun nods throughout this
episode which i i'm sure will be
continuing as the show progresses
doesn't look like there's a post-credits
scene
then why stick around yeah i was just
who are we honoring
whose hard work was this
all right i enjoyed that enjoyed it
quite a bit kind of felt like brad bird
directed that episode director of iron
giant and mission possible ghost
protocol
a couple other movies he's done too like
incredibles you know all right
tomorrowland tomorrowland that one
that's his biggest one it's the one
everyone loved the most uh yeah not a
flawless episode i got a couple of
things that i would definitely have a
couple of qualms about
but uh john what'd you think i had a lot
of fun with this i mean it took me maybe
a little time to get used to the kind of
pacing and the rhythm and how to kind of
sink into you know some of the more
tense moments based off of that but for
the most part i thought it was really
fun really imaginative it had a lot of
fun little like rhyming moments calling
back to captain america the first
avenger as well as other aspects of the
mcu and uh yeah i just thought like the
action was really punchy i liked a lot
of the different animation choices uh
you know it seems like they've gone with
something that is evidently cg for the
most part but that definitely wants to
hearken toward you know drawn and comic
book styles of animation and yeah i
think you you hit it on the head when
you said that in the credits of like you
know they they really
modeled this after you know a 40s serial
and kind of went with that and through
that lens uh i yeah for the most part i
thought it was really really fun
well yeah i think they did not just in
terms of its visual palette but also in
the style of its rhythm and its dialogue
yeah uh which did take a little bit of
adjusting too in terms of pacing
uh because yeah i mean for the most part
i really enjoyed it i think haley
atwell's voice work here is great and
you can kind of rush past some certain
beats
um due to the fact that peggy carter
herself has already been a soldier for
quite some time
and so her getting in the field i really
loved the wonder that would come across
captain carter's face
when she was first time using the shield
and being like wow this is awesome this
is incredible like i can't where's the
shield been my whole life this is
amazing like i really loved her
i'm excited for her to join the
live-action versions of the mcu it's
being reported that she's gonna be in
doctor strange too multiverse of madness
and seeing
her brought to life is exciting because
it's more than just female captain
america it's not it's a very different
rendition and i like that they played
into that with you know steve having
being the poster boy in captain america
the first avenger being used as like a
product and whereas her when she gets
the serum they're like you're a woman no
yeah yeah stay in the shadows yeah cell
warbo no there's no way you know
impossible don't even think about it so
i i thought it would even be more of a
debate over the fact that she's british
i know i was like
so many times they're like man the
president couldn't be more thrilled and
i'm like she's got a big old british
flag on your chest you know this must be
a real joint operation i thought they
would do a little bit more uh with that
quality to it and i do like uh some of
the the riffing that they would do where
you were dealing with the expectation of
where you think some of this would go
where it's because for the most part
it's
they've changed some stuff it's not a
hundred percent this for the most part
it was like the structure of captain
america the first adventure avenger
following those plot beats condensed
into 28 minutes
yeah is what most of this really was and
instead of starting off at the very and
because you're not
following steve rogers's specific
journey he's a supporting character here
they uh they kick it off right at the
lab with the super soldier serum and i
like how just in that that one little
beat right there uh with the assassin
who is actually played by richard
armitage and captain america the first
avenger
um and he get he gets to successfully
pull off the explosion here leading to a
failure on steve's end for getting the
super soldier serum so instead
carter goes in there and also dealing
like the expectation of is bucky gonna
fall off the train again instead it's
actually steve and then following that
same beat structure but with the role
reversal of steve and peggy at the very
end of them saying bye to each other you
owe me a dance and then same thing wakes
up in the future just a different way of
how she wakes up in the future
a bit of a gandalf the gray thing
fighting the ball rock
you fools yeah but instead of but but
yeah fighting there but it seems like
time just um went by for her re like the
real time of her felt like she fought
them the creature then bam wait and go
immediately yeah comes through the other
side to nick fury and hawkeye yeah i
really enjoyed um the way that played
out and there were some things that were
just direct homages like when she's
hitting the punching bag i think making
you think of the first avengers movie
when steve is hitting the punching bag
um and then you know like some of the
shots where she wake burst out with the
gun and she's leading the troops
famous shot i remember that from the
trailer even like oh what a cool shot
that is you know
um yeah breaking out the soldiers and
stuff going to the train
but i think my yeah my main issue with
it really is i wish this happened i wish
this episode was like 45 minutes yeah an
hour because it does move so fast to the
point where
all i felt the adventure i felt the fun
i felt the escapism i liked the vibe of
it a lot i actually really like the
animation because it did similar to how
i said this when i saw the steve clip
similar to how i felt about spider-man
and the spider-verse it does feel like a
comic book panel
sort of brought to life
um
but you know obviously with this very
specific type of approach so i
appreciated it and while i did really
enjoyed it and i felt the fun of it i
could never buy into like
the stakes or the overall emotional
drama
because it was just moving at a mile a
minute the whole time and then scenes
were just so short
that it didn't really have time to feel
much other than like the good feelings
of like this is fun or oh this is cute
with steve and peggy and i really liked
how they kept that intact
and got a different side to it because
you know in the in first avenger it it's
very much like she she seems really
drawn to him after he's all muscled up
and tall you know
like who loves that's not really what's
inside after all
it's all those muscles baby you know
peggy likes him because of who he is
inside yes i know uh but i love how even
after she gets all buffed up she still
seems really drawn to steve you know who
he is yeah it's granted steve does not
look as
weird he like he looks weird in the
first place
yeah he doesn't look like an emaciated
child he looks strange in the first one
he just looks like a little guy here
yeah exactly it's not like oh do you
have a condition you know yeah yeah are
you malnourished should i be donating a
few pennies a month yeah it looks like a
pretty normal dude for the most part
here just on the smaller side yeah and
then it goes to even further sell like
okay obviously then he could pilot this
big suit this hydro stomper suit yeah so
i love the romance between them still
but yeah to cap it off on that one point
it's the dr yeah like you said the drama
of it was like i'm not really buying
into the stakes here because i'm just
sort of absorbing all this fast-paced
information i'm not super worried like
i'm concerned for certain details but
yeah i wonder how the pace of these will
evolve as time goes because that was the
only thing that kept it feel like i
think these are in a unique position
because they're taking movies that
usually at least occupy the pg-13 space
between kit accessible and you know
stuff for you know a slightly older
audience and there is like a lot of
especially like gun violence in this
episode so i'm like there is a certain
like element of you know this seems like
it's not just aimed at kids so i feel
like yeah if they can maybe smooth out
the way that they balance certain of the
more supposed to be affecting story
beats with the pace like that would be
great because like the action like i
loved the way they grounded the action
and the way they shot so like it's
animation you could do whatever you want
and yeah i thought it was a really wise
choice to put the camera so to speak in
a lot of very tangible places you might
put a real camera but take advantage of
all the physics and all the you know
timing that you can play with to really
make that stuff feel like so engaged and
picturesque you know well that's where
it reminded me a lot of brad bird
because i remember when i saw the
incredibles watching these characters
with superpowers that we've seen brought
to live action before when i watch the
incredibles i go well what i love about
how they're handling it here
is
you can only capture this style with
animation you can only make this feel
believable in the world established
before our eyes through this type of
animation that's how i felt watching the
incredibles that's how i felt here like
she's essentially doing the kind of
action that you would apply to captain
america steve rogers but we're seeing it
captured in in a different way with
these like beautiful tracking shots and
weaving in and out of locations like i
love the shot where they're uh invading
the castle at the end and it's like a
profile
following
so like every time she like goes to a
bad guy like they're revealed on the
left side of the frame as you're
entering yeah that's like knocking them
out scroller and yeah kind of the shield
is always somewhere towards the center
of the frame like you're just following
that through the action yeah or like the
fun montage that they pulled off here uh
like like finding the people in the sky
and stuff like that was all great the
action itself was was awesome
undoubtedly it was it was really awesome
to behold and i thought like yeah they
they weren't able to capture it this way
like with captain america some of his
best actions like super russo brothers
gritty handheld you know
and this is really smooth fluid one
takes for a lot of it all yeah yeah so i
love i love that side of it and i like
what they did with steve here a lot i
really love i really loved how
the events here played out because
because they were able to successfully
get the tesseract because one part of
your brain might go well why didn't
howard stark build you know a hydro
stomper suit for peggy well he near the
tesseract in order to do it so the fact
that they were able to succeed in
getting the tester act and then
implementing that into the hydrostat
pursuit allowing steve to still be
involved in the action there it's just i
can't help but feel like ah there's so
much emotional weight to these things i
could have felt more nuanced and could
have felt heavier
if
the
episode was able to breathe better at
all
yeah it doesn't really breathe but
here's what i'm here's what i'm thinking
to give it a benefit of the down it's
not just a marvel fanboy like i'm just
thinking about first episode installment
this is essentially
hear me out here this is essentially a
remake of captain america the first
avenger but you're gender swapping in a
way right whoa culture no no no not what
it is it's a what-if scenario uh it's
essentially what it is with some few
changes here that i really like such as
like howard stark getting involved in
the field and really getting to hang out
with him a lot more like he was one of
the big highlights to me of this one was
you really feel like you're hanging out
with howard stark and i loved uh i think
dominic cooper does reprise his role
here i was missing some of the credit
names as i was listening to jeffrey
wright's voiceover but i think i think
dominic cooper does dominique cooper
right cooper cooper yeah and then i
think sebastian stan also did like bucky
and it was definitely sebastian's stuff
yeah uh but yeah having dominic cooper
back in here and really getting a toy
around with the character was so much
fun and having him in the i like
that um you know
nazi propaganda sci-fi horror
experimenting in castle like i really
liked that a lot and then bringing in
the obelisk again was awesome like that
was that was such a neat touch as you
think of like the wolfenstein games or
something like that yeah yeah you think
of like wolfenstein and how do you think
of like old gothic horror with the way
they're in this like old castle for
hydra and he's got this like
frankenstein layer like it managed to
meld all the pulp of the era it felt
like together into sort of one big you
know extravaganza right
uh but plot-wise it's still a remake of
captain america the first avenger
where as i'm under the impression
like for what we've seen teased for the
black uh the
yeah the black panther one that's hollow
one that that while it's swapping out
star-lord with t'challa it's not a
remake of guardians of the galaxy yeah
yeah yeah that the other ones that
aren't like remakes of them this was an
introduction this was the one to set you
up for a what if scenario where it's
like now we can swap out characters what
if it was this person what if it was
that person but we could do a different
plot this was the same plot as captain
america the first avenger pretty much
like everything will really there's
nothing really refreshing about red
skull here i i like hearing ross to see
him it's neat to see him but i'm like
you pretty much did the same first scene
from first avenger yeah yeah
just a super short condensed version of
it
and then the other stuff didn't i
thought like oh maybe we're going to do
something to make red skull a little
cooler and no not really um so yeah red
school really wasn't anything special
here
and it's like i said the benefit of the
doubt that i have is that it's the first
episode and it's a remake of the first
avengers so then i feel like the next
one's moving forward won't
be that yeah and i mean that seems like
a kind of a solid way to acclimate
everybody who's not obsessing over these
things is to take something very
familiar and and represent your entire
premise with that go what if we took
something you've all seen probably and
we plucked a couple details and changed
them around and yeah it's a good primer
for sure well i also wonder if that
probably makes it feel even faster
yeah
when you feel like you're watching a
remake of first avenger with some swap
outs that feels 28 minutes versus two
hours
yeah you can really feel the weight of
all this yeah it's cut out yeah it's
just a highlight reel of them yeah
yeah so uh i think that works against it
yeah um but in terms of the
swashbuckling fun of feeling like you're
in a 1940 cereal the action is really
cool i really liked the voiceover work
quite a bit there were some characters
that felt a tad bit off um but the main
players i really enjoyed i loved uh just
getting to hang out with bucky in the
sense of he's not winner soldier here
he's not traumatized buck yeah he's just
like good old neighbor he was never
by reality what if he got to be spared
yeah it was fun getting all that um so
yeah we'll we'll see if that criticism
still holds up for the the episodes
moving forward
but it also doesn't just feel like
solely a show aimed at kids it it felt
cinematic enough for me like this
especially in the way they capture their
action scenes for a first episode it
felt appropriately cinematic
uh but yeah i would have liked it to
have been like
15 minutes longer yeah
just for that extra breathing room to
let some of its because it seemed like
we already saw this in first avenger
rush rush rush yeah and then when it
started to slow down like when steve and
uh peggy are about to kiss i really like
that
yeah well and because of that it gives
you the kind of a feeling like you're
seeing something half new
and yeah
so you're still kind of sitting here
going okay but now i want to see you go
like completely off into your own
terrain but in terms of uh
introducing captain carter she was great
absolutely she was amazing and it wasn't
much of the episode but i liked uh the
sort of wrap around of the watcher and
jeffrey wright just his his voice is
such a great way to pull you in and out
of these stories i feel like the watcher
will get
an actual scene at some point in the
show maybe an episode yes
um
it's just him looking at people it was
interesting because it looked like she
because the the first avenger uh captain
no
the first avengers movie yes
starts off when there's hawkeye and nick
fury
tesseract portal
and so she does wake up in like the
beginning of the first avengers movie
but it's not loki coming through
it's an interesting
mashing of things that they did here
uh so yeah all right guys what did you
think about this episode leave your
thoughts down below uh subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button
and hey we will do a
maria hammond
maria
you are like the captain carter of our
patreon page
just a
strong
badass woman who's kicking so much ass
left and right and always looking now
for the little people like john and i
we need more women like you out there
saving puny men like us
propping us up and making us feel
confident even though we don't have any
natural abilities of our own and mostly
you rely on machinery
take it away
but how awesome would that be plus i
mean you know you've got a good loving
heart but you're also a fighter so you
would be the perfect person to step into
the field i imagine you you smack around
some sort of you know [ __ ] bradley
whitford style general who's
underestimating you go out there bring
back a tesseract or something sacrifice
yourself for love maria
you would be my hero she doesn't even
need super soldier serum no she could
kick captain carter's ass yeah you could
do that right now
let's put it to the test
i'm sending over
gina carano
to your home right now
oh that's gonna be good i'll i'll send
over like a kiddie pool that you guys
can fill with mud or something
and then on top of that we'll send over
britney spears's parents oh yeah
yeah and and why not her sister to
everybody
from that family
just went off the deep end yeah but it's
okay
i don't appreciate you maria you know
that you're you're the bomb you're the
bomb.com captain that's my mom
captain mom
maybe we'll try again
[Music]